endlich mal ein bisschen action bei
pixum mike wird von keule verprügelt die
257 sind immer für eine ware schon gut
auch bei der frage wo sie tools
aufgegabelt haben das und viel mehr
jetzt im community video little mami 93
man kommt mal wieder ein perfektes
dinner mit sayfuse etc ja sehr sehr bald
wir haben jetzt keinen genauen zeitplan
dem wir da uns schon ein geht dir unser
zeitmanagement und so aber ja also auf
jeden fall kommt auf jeden fall ein
perfektes die nase der wald und feld der
wixxer somit ist ja würde ich auch sagen
mal gucken aber es kommt auf jeden fall
wie am bock nochmal aber wir müssen halt
richtig krasse scheiße finden die wir
auch erst mal wieder fressen können aber
josef koch ist unterwegs im land der
unendlichen köstlichkeiten und wird uns
wieder einiges auf den teller genetik
ein richtig krank aufzunehmen grüße von
mir
sexualität mit genetik kann ich mir
vorstellen geschlechtsverkehr in einem
dunklen raum mit über fetten männern zu
haben
die jungs sind richtig cool also ich mit
den auf jeden fall klar
ja ja ich will xxxx gefragt wo habt ihr
jools aufgegabelt und uns auf rügen wird
keine ahnung wir haben es einfach
getroffen und uns in einer verliebt und
dann sind wir entgegen des
sonnenuntergangs richtung horizont
gelaufen
und seitdem sind wir zusammen morgens
aufgewacht löffelchen viererkette und
seitdem sind wir zusammen in die kamera
hallo markus schnitzler lukoil erfragen
also stelle ich dir heute warum martin
favorit zu sehen was haltet ihr davon
auch mitmacht
das schon zwei prisen schweiz stimmt es
passiert mag es matt nach und so
schlecht gelaunt als ich mich auf dem
zeltplatz mainz vorgestellt ab weil er
auf drogen
wenn ja dann verzeiht dass man durch
ließ gerüchte dass hier keine ausgrenzt
finde ich schon ok mal unter und ich
wünsche ihnen auch schlecht sichtbar als
der krieg die weil ich den ich gerne mag
noch eine frage war eigentlich auch in
der rba beet würdet ihr gerne im grab
sehen und laptop würde dir sofort und
das vertrag nehmen ja ich bin auch mal
backup und genug genervt album kommt ich
bin pleite das soll wer auf youtube
scheren so ich geh mal auf das rba ding
auf jeden fall ein wir waren schon
meiner rba ich hab da mitgemacht rheins
vorrunden-ko land auch mitgemacht der
wurde gepflegt in der letzten runde bei
in sein bett aber schließen irgendwie
faxen am rechner gemacht hat ich kann
ich keine letzte runde hochladen konnte
mich einfach ein bastard beat
hochgeladen auf den man meiner meinung
nach nicht retten konnte aber mein
gegner hat er irgendwie zwei sätze
darauf gesagt also hat er die punkte
gibt halt die fresse
immerhin waschen hat schließen in der
trainings liegt musste der anfang weil
die denn irgendwie weg fanden in bad
honnef kann ich auch nachvollziehen und
vbt ich glaube wir hätten so ein scheiß
gemacht wenn wir jetzt nicht hätten
gesagt hätten hätten wenn wir da jetzt
mitmachen würden dann würden doch ganz
ehrlich wenn wir da wenn wir dann ein
paar runden weit kommen würden dann
würden auch die die gegen uns
rausfliegen voll rum pissen und
rumheulen daad unfaire weil also dann
wäre doch blöd und unter bedingungen
will ich das nicht machen
ich habe zu viele leute dann glaube ich
die dann für mich wurden unehrlich
wurden würden und das wäre dann scheiße
die einfach nur mein weiterkommen klar
machen wollen und das volle stress oder
competition muss auf jeden fall krass da
sein und das ist mal durfte zu wissen
ich habe jetzt ein geiles video weil ich
viele coole leute kennt ihr die
vielleicht nicht kennen so und dann
sagen einfach alles ok kommt schließen
go weiter dings sie ihr alter und dann
ist da
das nicht schließen aber da kann man
nicht als crew mitmachen
warum war michael schlecht gelaunt bis
danach waren worden
warum hast du so schlecht gelaunt auf
dem spiel wir haben keine schuhe von
snacks bekommen punkt 1 reebok hatte
keine schuhe bekommen
snipes hat uns was die cat habe ich von
snipes nur einen tag das essen
punkt zwei displays irgendwie komisch
gewesen punkt 3 m series an heute
vollgelaufen punkt 4
und ich hatte glaube ich keinen job in
dem moment meinte das kann seine fans
irene und cool oder was wir dem früher
ab der ist immer an dem vorbei gelaufen
ich stehen geblieben und hat hat sich
nicht mit ihm unterhalten hat nicht
gesagt bist du nicht jeden fall würde
ich noch dazu sagen
drops noch mal an alle vbt jungs ihr
seid cool und der machen weil
säbelzahntiger remix mit alt was für
mammut remix wir machen säbelzahntiger
remix männer gucken abgehen aber wir
feiern die auf jeden fall alle richtig
hart und vbt grüße bastian und ich grüße
lens und ich grüße weekend und ich grüße
da so und ich grüße
3+ und wie sie nicht alle heißen ist
sehr schön was ihr da macht
was haltet ihr von der französischen
revolution möchte sie beging wissen
mittel wenig bis gar nichts also war
schon ziemlich uninteressant nicht so
gebildet die irans französisch ich weiß
nichts davon was aber eine revolution
auf jeden fall das ist schon mal ganz
gut viva la diva jools unsere revolution
geht auch bloß diese frage und anderen
guten kontakt zu fragen
ok also kollegah ist halt einfach der
boss mehr muss man ja wohl jetzt zu
sorgen meine freunde face ist ein
[ __ ] genetik haben wir bereits
erwähnt das sind schöne jungs und ich
finde unsere mutter auch schön wie waren
die anderen zwei fragen dieser album
denn er sagte er wird kommen irgendwann
honig 3 er meint diese sampler keule wie
lautete die andere frage habe vergessen
ich könnte sagen wir sagen sie mir wie
ist der kontakt zur selfmade records
zustande kommt müssen fragen zu liegt
mich war's aber es liegt denn fünf
schule 90 schule
fünf internet ich auch denken hören von
youtube und klicks machen klicks machen
auf youtube hören und vorgruppen tour
bei mal wieder immer mal selfmade wir
haben ja hin und wieder mal irgendwo
dann so aus nettigkeit die vorgruppe
gemacht damit die auch ein paar karten
verkaufen für ihre touren
nein war spaß navy war schon weiß nicht
wie oft erschließen hatte die ganze
teams verkehrsstaus fest becker
mitgemacht
da waren wir dann auch hier und da mal
der kontakt der hat sich so schleichen
und auch nasa hat eure fragen im
community video beantwortet zb der nach
dem besten rapper und er hat sich für
kollege entschieden als dem technisch
besten rapper der welt für ihn und auch
haudegen waren bei uns sie erklären ob
sie gerne oder nicht so gerne mit den
böhsen onkelz verglichen werden das und
viel mehr und viel mehr videos gibt's
natürlich auf klicks um aber jetzt hier
die beiden verlinkt ihr könnt euch
entscheiden
und ansonsten bis dann packt an